the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi recall that in our previous two
lectures we have been discussing the
concepts of velocity and acceleration of
particles moving along a curve and we
had pointed out originally that the most
natural definition was in terms of say I
and J or I J and K components in other
words Cartesian coordinates and then we
showed in the last lecture that
tangential and normal components form a
rather important system of vectors and
now what we would like to do is to
motivate the use of polar coordinate
types of vectors and again it's
interesting to point out that we could
have introduced polar coordinates into
our course at any one of a number of
times in fact one of the problems with
the traditional mathematics curriculum
was that frequently topics were put in
just for the sake of filling a chapter
they fit into the space they didn't need
any additional prerequisites so we put
them in there and many a typical
traditional high school algebra book
could have had the chapter shuffled with
no loss of continuity what we're trying
to do in this particular course is to
motivate why particular concepts would
have been invented if they had not
already have been invented previously in
particular in dealing with particles
moving in a plane or in space there
comes the time when one considers the
very important physical application
known as a central force field now in a
central force field and by the way this
is where the would polar coordinates
comes up very naturally and why we call
today's lecture polar coordinates see in
the central force field what we mean is
that the only force acting happens to be
located at a fixed position and so that
the force of attraction no matter where
the particle is wherever that particle
is the force is always directed along
the line either towards or away
depending upon whether its attraction or
distraction yeah repulsion huh it's
always acting this way if we're using
Newtonian mechanics since the force is
proportional to the accelerate
it says what that a very natural
direction for acceleration would be
along the direction that connects the
origin meaning the location of the
central force to the particle well you
see once this is done it becomes a very
natural thing to say okay if you're
going to be talking about central force
fields why not introduce new variables
after all it seems that the important
thing now in measuring the central force
is to know how far the particle is from
the force and also I suppose to locate
the position of the particle once you
know how far away it is you would like
to know what angle the radius vector
makes with the positive x-axis right and
in this sense that would be all that we
would need to motivate polar coordinates
now you see once the motivation is there
we can always study the subject
independently of whether the motivation
haven't been given or not in other words
now we say look it it's important to
study polar coordinates why is it
important because we want to study
central force fields but the structure
of polar coordinates is going to be the
same whether we study central force
fields or not then you see once we
finish our study of polar coordinates
then we say okay now let's go back as a
particular application to central force
fields any rate without further ado
let's tackle the subject of polar
coordinates again many of you may be
very very familiar with polar
coordinates some of you a bit rusty to
play it safe I have divided the study
guide in such a way that there will be
two units devoted to polar coordinates
but that this one lecture will cover
both of those two units that this
lecture as usual will be the overview
and I guess this is the best you can do
with mathematics beyond the point beyond
the certain point mathematics ceases to
be a spectator sport and you just have
to do to your hands with the
computations and that the basic theory
as simple as it may seem is
straightforward it's just a case of
picking up the computational know-how
together with a familiarity so you feel
at ease with the concepts so let's just
quickly
go through the highlights of polar
coordinates they start off in a very
deceptively simple way namely given a
point P in the plane if we elect to use
Cartesian coordinates the point P can be
labeled as X comma Y on the other hand
using polar coordinates referring to
this diagram at least one would be would
tend as we mentioned before to label
this point R comma theta where R is the
distance of the point from the origin
and theta the angle that we're talking
about over here
notice by the way that there is a very
simple set of formula by which we can
switch from one pair of representations
to the other for example to express x
and y in terms of iron theta one simply
has that x equals R cosine theta y
equals R sine theta okay and conversely
to express our and theta in terms of x
and y 1 has that R squared equals x
squared plus y squared and the tan theta
is y over X by the way you might wonder
why I didn't write R equals the square
root of x squared plus y squared the
reason I wrote this is that we're going
to get into some complications very
shortly complicate complications which I
saw skim over and if you see how long
winded I am skimming over is not going
to be that short but short relative to
the treatment that we're going to give
it in the exercises there are certain
complications that set in because R can
be negative by the same token somebody
says instead of writing tan theta equals
y over X why couldn't you say that theta
was the inverse tangent Y over X use the
inverse trig functions remember that the
inverse trig functions require a
principal value domain for the tangent
that's what between minus PI over 2 and
PI over 2 and notice that the angle
theta certainly is not restricted to
that range theta could be in the second
quadrant the third quadrant it can wind
around in other words one of the
luxuries about Cartesian coordinates was
that they were terribly formally stilted
there were no two ways to represent the
same point you know in the study of
Cartesian coordinates one can say to a
point position is everything in life
that once you change the
point-i once you change the coordinates
you've changed the point for example
there's no possible way for the point X
comma Y to equal the points a 2 comma 3
unless X equals 2 or y equals 3 in other
words for Cartesian coordinates the only
way two points could be equal would be
if they were equal coordinate by
coordinate the complication that sets in
for polar coordinates is that
unfortunately this simple result no
longer remains true for example if I
tell you that the point R 1 comma theta
1 is equal to the point R 2 comma theta
2 it does not imply that's a slash
through the arrow here this is means
it's false it does not imply that I can
conclude that R 1 equals R 2 and the
theta 1 equals theta 2 to be sure it's
possible that R 1 equals R 2 and it's
possible at theta 1 equals theta 2 but
it doesn't have to happen well the nice
thing about mathematics is that we can
always give examples is to back up what
we're saying let's look at a few
examples let's look for example at what
happens if we using Radian measure if we
replace the angle by some integral
multiple of 2pi added onto that angle in
other words let's take the point R 1
comma theta 1 and compare that point
with the point whose coordinates are R 1
comma theta 1 plus 2 K pi see look at
the I values are the same here all right
but look at theta 1 and theta 1 plus 2 K
PI notice that unless K is 0 these are
different angles you know it's rather
interesting you know I know in high
school this happens about people
youngsters will tend to say things like
30 degrees is the same as 390 degrees
and in a way they're right except that
they say it in such a way that's
dangerous certainly one should not
confuse 30 degrees with 390 degrees what
one usually means is that any
trigonometric function of 30 degrees is
equal to that same trigonometric
function of 390 degrees in other words
the technical way of saying it is that
the trigonometric functions are periodic
with period 2pi in Radian measure 360
degrees in degree measure in other words
for example using Radian measure
notice that the sine of theta one is
equal to the sine of theta one plus 2 pi
K where K is some integer here but the
theta one is unequal to theta one plus 2
pi K if K is unequal to 0 if K is equal
to 0 of course this happens to be a
special case you see the whole point is
that you see all it means in terms of a
graph if you were to plot the curve y
equals sine X it is possible for what
many different values of theta many
different values of X to give the same
value of sine X what this means by the
way in terms of polar coordinates is
that it certainly makes a difference
whether we talk about an angle of 30
degrees with the pot making an angle of
30 degrees with a positive align making
an angle of 30 degrees with the positive
x-axis or making 390 degrees because you
see that 390 degrees seems to indicate
that you've made one full circuit and
then an additional 30 degrees as far as
position is concerned you're in the same
place but for example in terms of fuel
consumption it uses more fuel say to go
through the 390 degrees than to go
through the 30 degrees but at any rate
that's not the point we want to make
here the point is notice in this
particular example that this is two
different names for the same point but
we cannot conclude that coordinate by
coordinate the coordinates are equal
that's not the worst of it the worst of
it is that our and/or theta
don't even have to be positive another
way of saying that is they may be
negative for example to capitalize on
the idea of vector notation what one
frequently does is says look at let's
talk about a negative distance and by a
negative distance we'll identify that
what's cents in other words let's call
this angle here theta then if we go if
we look at the C notice what you're
really saying here is you're assuming
that the radius vector when you're
calling this angle theta has this
particular sense suppose you want to
talk about this vector notice that this
would be the right sense
if the angle here happened to be what
theta plus pi 180 degrees PI radians now
what you say is if you're looking at
this particular point notice that with
respect to this vector
you must go what negative our units in
other words you must move in the
opposite sense of this particular vector
to get to this point
and again this is a touchy enough
concept that we're going to do this in
great detail in the learning exercises
but the point is notice that our comma
theta is a different name for the same
point as that which is named by minus R
comma theta plus pi you see that let's
just look at that one more time to make
sure see on the one hand reading this
angle and this distance this is our
comma theta on the other hand reading it
from this angle the value is minus R and
the angle is theta plus pi and I'll get
a different piece of chalk in a minute
because this doesn't seem to be writing
too well but let's not worry about that
for the time being let me give you an
example
look at the curve whose polar equation
as R equals sine squared theta notice
that if theta equals PI over 6 the sine
of PI over 6 is 1/2 1/2 squared is 1/4
so notice that R equals 1/4 theta equals
PI over 6
satisfies this particular equation now
notice that another name for the same
point using this recipe here is minus
1/4 comma 7 PI over 6 but without even
looking you should be able to see that
it's impossible for this value of R and
this value of theta to satisfy this
equation in particular notice that sine
squared theta can't be negative just by
reading this equation R can never be
negative therefore how can our equals
minus 1/4 possibly satisfy this equation
and this is where the bit complication
comes in in terms of simultaneous
equations and what have you here we have
what two different names for the same
point yet by one of its names the point
satisfies the equation and by its other
name or another name
it doesn't satisfy the equation and this
is a very very touchy thing because
you'd like to believe what the point
belongs to a curve not the name of a
point and that one of the difficulties
with polar coordinates is that to check
whether a point belongs to a curve or
not if the point as named by one way
doesn't satisfy the equation you still
have to check other possible names to
see whether they satisfy the equation or
not and this is a very complicated topic
and this is why some of our learning
exercises in this unit take so many
pages it's more or less devoted to
giving you insight into this if you
don't already have this insight but
anyway let's continue on in general
terms here the next most important thing
to talk about is to make sure that we
understand what polar coordinates really
mean namely when someone says I am
thinking of the curve C whose polar
equation is R equals sine theta okay he
does not mean plot R versus theta this
way and call that the curve C you see
notice that even though you're calling
this R and theta using the axes to be at
right angles this way
no matter how you slice it you're still
using Cartesian coordinates here only
with theta replacing the name of X and
are replacing the name Y see this is not
what's meant remember that when you're
talking about polar coordinates are
specifically measures what the distance
of the particular point on C from the
origin and theta measures the angle that
that radius vector makes with the x-axis
for example what we do mean by the curve
whose pole equation is R equals sine
theta is the circle of radius 1/2
centered on the y axis you see at the
point what in Cartesian coordinates x is
0 Y is 1/2 and I claim that that's what
we mean by the curve R equals sine theta
and how can I prove that to you well the
easiest way to prove that to you is by
some elementary geometry namely I call
this point our comma theta
I now draw in these guidelines notice
that by definition this length is R
since this is an inscribed angle on a
diameter it's a 90-degree angle
therefore since this angle is Theta and
both of these angles are complements of
a 90-degree angle this angle must also
be theta and now if I just look at this
particular diagram I read this right
triangle and immediately I see what that
from this right triangle are equal sine
theta in other words the curve C whose
polar equation is R equal sine theta is
this particular curve by the way you
know we often get indoctrinated into
seeing things in a very natural way in
terms of a native tongue now my
father-in-law was brought up in Russia
he had a little grocery store he spoke
fluent English but when he added up
customers bills he always added in
Russian he was more at home with Russian
numerals and this always impressed me
until I realized that I was the same way
only I used base 10 numerals instead of
base seven or something like this and
the same thing happens with polar versus
Cartesian coordinates
even though polar coordinates are
independent of Cartesian coordinates the
fact remains that we're probably more at
home with Cartesian coordinates than we
are with polar coordinates consequently
one very common trick when we can get
away with it is to take a polar equation
and translate it into an equivalent
Cartesian equation namely given R equals
sine theta and remembering that R
squared is x squared plus y squared and
that our sine theta is y we multiply
both sides of this equation by R to get
R squared equals R sine theta this leads
to x squared plus y squared equals Y if
we then complete the square etc we find
that in Cartesian coordinates this is
the equation of the circle centered at
the point 0 comma 1/2 with radius equal
to 1/2 the thing that's very very
important to note here is that in terms
of x and y the relationship x squared
plus y squared equals y is not
structurally the same as the
relationship R equals sine theta in
other words the curve C is the same
whether you
use its Cartesian form or whether you
use its polar form but what's very
important to note is that the
relationship between R and theta is not
algebraically the same as the
relationship between x and y but the
important point is that since the curve
C does not measure R versus theta as
being at right angles to each other that
if you were given R equal sine theta and
you compute the I D theta which in this
case simply would be what cosine theta
that does not give the slope of C you
see this is what I want you to
understand if I compute the Rd theta and
want to interpret that as a slope it's
not a slope of the curve C it's a slope
of this particular curve which wasn't C
in other words this is the curve that
marries that map that measures our
versus theta in terms of of Cartesian
coordinates that the ID theta just shows
you how R is changing with respect to
theta it does not tell you how the curve
is rising at that point and again more
information is given on this in terms of
exercises but that's what I do want you
to understand it does not mean that you
can't compute the slope of this curve at
any point it does mean that if you want
the slope and you compute it by letting
it equal dr d-theta you will get an
answer this way but it won't be the
slope that you're looking for in fact
what I hope that you can see rather
simply here is the following to get the
slope of a line it doesn't really say I
want the slope of the tangent line to
the curve at this particular point it
doesn't really make much difference
whether I use the angle fee which the
radius which the tangent line makes with
the positive x-axis or whether I use V
or fire I don't this angle is called
either fee of Phi and this angle is
called C oops I I get all mixed up with
the Greek lazio in fact coming into work
mm into a disc jockey and he was making
fun of how in drug stores now
you can get a full course meal but you
can't get any medicines anymore and he
was talking about his friends who got
all A's and melly in pharmacy school and
they flunked them out because they
didn't know how to make a
sandwich I almost flunked out of math
because I had trouble with the Greek
alphabet here but look at forget about
that the thing I want you to see is I
want to know the direction of this line
if it's convenient to use fee I'll use
fee if it's convenient to use C I'll use
see what is fee fee is the angle that
the tangent line makes with the positive
x-axis what is C C is the angle that the
tangent line makes with the radius
vector now as I'll show you in some of
our exercises to use the definition that
the slope is 10 fee and translating that
from Cartesian coordinates into polar
coordinates is a very very messy job
what turns out to be very very
interesting at least from my point of
view is that not only is the angle C sy
more natural to use than fee when you're
dealing with polar coordinates but it
almost turns out that because it was
more natural there's a simple simpler
formula for it in other words whereas
the formula for tan fee is very very
complicated in Part II in polar
coordinates the formula for tan sy is
very simply given by R divided by dr
d-theta in other words if I take R
divide that by the ID theta what I get
is the tangent of this angle now look at
once I have the tangent of this angle
it's very simple to construct the
tangent line that's what I want you to
see suppose this is the point P and this
is my pole o for polar coordinates and
suppose now given that our with some
function of theta
suppose now I've computed the ID theta
I've divided that into our and I've now
found what 10 perseus what I do is I
take the line of action that joins the
origin to P I construct the angle see
draw this line and whatever that line is
that is the line which is tangent to my
particular curve at the point P but the
thing I want you to see is that we do
not need Cartesian coordinates at all in
order to be able to tackle calculus
properties when an equation is written
polar coordinates but what there is a
tendency to do is what that when we're
dealing with polar coordinates since
we're more at home with Cartesian
coordinates we will often be tempted to
switch everything into Cartesian
coordinates which is perfectly fair game
but the important thing is to remember
that all of our calculus results can be
derived independently of whether
Cartesian coordinates were ever invented
for example the final concept I want to
talk about in this lecture is how one
would have studied area if one had only
polar coordinates and had never had
Cartesian coordinates suppose I'm by the
way notice also that in terms of coppola
coordinates one is more interested in
sectors than in rectangular grids in
other words if you look at something
ranging from theta one to theta two you
think of something caught between two
rays here and let's suppose I wanted the
area of this particular region where
this particular curve happened to have
the form say R equals G of theta I don't
killer this this is called R equals G of
theta now the interesting point again
and I keep saying interesting point
because they are interesting points that
if you've really taken part 1 of this
course seriously you're going to be
amazed to see how much free mileage you
get out of Part two just by translating
things back in to our general theorems
of part one let me see how I could find
the area of this particular region the
idea is I'll take a little increment of
area here between these two black lines
what I'll do now remember my basic
building blocks are now our values what
I'll do now is I'll pick the smallest
value of R that gives me an arc that
lies inside this segment and I'll pick
the biggest value of R that encloses
this segment notice what I do is I'll
let our capital R sub capital M denote
this radius so that's this distance from
here to here
I'll let little R sub little m represent
this distance what I'm saying is if I
now swing two arcs my area theorems from
the first semester my areum axioms from
the first pie of the course are still
valid namely the smaller arc the smaller
sector is contained in
side the Delta a that I'm looking for
and the larger sector contains the
region that I'm looking for in other
words the region that I'm looking for
Delta a is caught between the areas of
these two sectors now how do you find
the area of a sector what you do is is
you take the area of the entire circle
and divide it by the fractional part of
the circle that you're taking for
example the area of the circle whose
radius is capital R sub M is PI R sub M
Squared
now what portion of the circle am i
taking the angle is Delta Theta I'm
using Radian measures so the entire
swinging angle would have been 2 pi so
I'm taking Delta Theta over 2 pi of the
entire circle so that's the area of the
larger sector what is the area of the
smaller sector the area of the smaller
sector is the area of the entire circle
PI R sub little M squared times again
what Delta theta over 2 pi and because
Delta a is embedded between these two
the region is embedded between these two
it's area is caught between these two
areas and if I now solve for Delta a I
simplify I cancel the PI's I get the
Delta a is caught between 1 1/2 capital
R sub M Squared Delta Theta and 1/2
little R sub M Squared Delta Theta I now
divide through by Delta Theta and I make
a non crucial assumption here that Delta
Theta is greater than 0
remembering that Delta Theta is negative
all I have to do is reverse the signs of
the inequalities the only reason I
assumed the delta theta was positive is
that I wouldn't change the direction of
the inequalities a similar demonstration
will hold when Delta Theta is negative
the important point is I then divide
through by Delta Theta I get Delta a
over Delta Theta is caught between one
half little R sub M Squared and one half
capital R sub M Squared now as I let
Delta Theta approach zero what does that
mean I'm gonna let Delta Theta close in
over here approach zero what's happening
here this is a fixed value of R notice
that little R sub m and capital R sub M
as delta theta approaches zero they're
both being pushed closer and closer to
our
in other words as delta theta approaches
zero R sub M little m and R capital R
sub M both approach are provided that R
is a continuous function of theta in
other words there are no breaks from the
curve here okay the important point then
is what we can then take limits as delta
theta approaches zero and we find that
the ad theta is the limit as delta theta
approaches 0 Delta a divided by Delta
Theta which simply is what now we come
back here as Delta theta approaches zero
little R sub M and capital R sub M both
approach R and therefore this common
limit becomes 1/2 R squared therefore
integrating this between what limits
between theta 1 and theta 2 I find that
the area of my region is the integral
from theta 1 to theta 2 1/2 R squared D
theta which of course means what it's
integral 1/2 R is G of theta so I square
that times D theta and notice that this
is a function of theta alone and so I
can find this particular area what's
crucial to understand is that the area
does not change just because you're
dealing with polar coordinates rather
than Cartesian coordinates but rather
the form of the equation changes what I
mean by that is something like this
let's suppose I have a region like this
given this region this region is an
animal it doesn't know whether you're
looking at it in polar coordinates or in
Cartesian coordinates in Cartesian
coordinates it's bounded above by the
curve y equals f1 of X and it's bounded
below by the curve y equals f2 of X from
what we studied in the first semester
the area of the region R in Cartesian
coordinates is the integral from 0 to a
f1 of X minus f2 of X DX on the other
hand if I call this curve R equals G of
theta in terms of polar coordinates and
the initial angle is theta 1 and the
terminal angle here is Theta 2 then the
area of that same region R is given to
be
one half integral from theta one to
theta to G of theta squared D theta
mathematically this integral in terms of
X and this integral in terms of theta
look completely different but the
crucial point is they are simply
different expressions for the same
answer which of the two is the better
one to use it depends on the particular
problem if for example a problem begs
for a polar coordinates interpretation
use polar coordinates in fact that none
of polar coordinates and Cartesian
coordinates can both be bad sets of
equations who knows it's not the point
the point is that we now have two
coordinate systems there are others that
we will define as the course goes on but
the important point is that we are now
ready to tackle motion in the plane for
central force fields if we so desire at
this particular moment I do so desire so
the chances are that next time we will
be talking about velocity and
acceleration vectors in polar
coordinates at any rate until next time
goodbye funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate